[Music]
forest johnson has admitted that he was
at a party in the number 10 garden in
may 2020 even if he claims he thought it
was a work event
at pmq's yesterday kirsten called on the
prime minister to resign saying he was a
pathetic spectacle of a man rod little
in his column for the magazine agrees
and writes that the sooner johnson has
gone the better
james forsyth meanwhile in his cover
piece as well this might be one mistake
too far are we really seeing the end of
boris johnson rod and james join me now
rod in this week's magazine you find
common calls with the likes of kirsten
douglas ross the scottish conservatives
leader um in saying that ultimately the
sooner boris johnson goes the better and
what's brought you to this conclusion
well what's brought me to this
conclusion it's a rather moral
uh the rather pompous phrase that he's
lost all moral authority you could argue
that he lost all moral authority every
previous time he's lied but in this one
where it's so
patently clear and to such
uh uh fury from the public uh then i
think it's all gone but i mean the real
reason he has to go is because he's of
no use anymore um
in that boris's deal with the
conservative party is you know i will be
incompetent and boris like but i will
win new elections but that doesn't look
very likely at the moment um he's miles
behind the polls i think
the the lowest victories have been in
ten years uh behind labor so so that
thing which boris wants to have which is
that he could win the elections no
longer looks as if it's true the the
counter argument
i suppose
uh and what some of the conservatives
will cling to
is that whilst boris is incompetent and
lies reflexively and
seemingly every juncture um
he gets the big things right such as
brexit such as winning in 2019 and
crucially you know and we ought to give
him credit for this uh telling sage to
get stuffed
three weeks ago you know all of those
were good decisions uh which i suspect
the public rather likes him for
but it's become outweighed and i think i
just think his position is pretty much
untenable
and james that argument which um rogers
uh summarized is one that michael gove
made to tory mps this week at meeting
the 1922 committee he was there to talk
about cladding and leveling up but gave
a speech saying on the big calls that
the prime minister is still right and
that's why he should have their backing
do you think that the prime minister
does have the backing of the majority of
the parliamentary party right now
i think the majority of the
parliamentary party right now
don't want uh the blood and drama of a
leadership contest
but i think they are sitting and waiting
to see
uh how the public react you know
rod's right the tory party's
relationship with boris johnson has
always been very transactional uh i
don't think the tory party would have
made boris johnson leader except in the
circumstances they were in where you
know they had just come i think fifth in
in in the european elections uh they
were polling very badly they looked to
be set for a kind of complete electoral
wipeout
and you know as as as one uh someone
who's known boris johnson for for as
long as rod bonds put it to me you know
the tory party were only ever going to
turn to him when they were kind of
two-nil down with uh uh 15 minutes to go
and you know he was there their super
sub in those circumstances he came on uh
he won them a majority of a size but i
don't think any other tory could have
done
uh
i think the danger of him now is if a
sense goes that he's moved from
electoral asset to liability then i
think you will see the ruthless side of
the tory party
rod boris johnson did offer an apology
or at least a part apology at prime
minister's questions this week and
saying you can understand why people
were upset
even if perhaps technically just
technically he still believes he was
within the rules um did that sway you at
all um his apology
yes it swayed me in the other direction
that he should go even quicker
i mean it wasn't an apology it was a it
was a weasley little tony blair kind of
non-apology apology uh in that he
apologized if people were upset uh so
nothing to do with him he apologized
that there was that the party could have
been better arranged
maybe they should have had it inside
whilst always stating that uh uh that uh
he hadn't broken any rules
you know it was it was a non-apology and
i thought for the first
three or four questions at question time
um
kirsten got it absolutely right and was
rather good uh and
i suppose the problem will come for
boris
when we find out the results of this
investigation
i think
uh the thing which may hasten the
conservative party view and james will
put me right on this is
if it is found that boris
was technically not breaking the law
because of course
downing street is crowned property
uh but if that is the only reason that
the law wasn't broken then i think that
is a technicality which the public
simply will not swallow and i suspect
foreign
james do you agree that do you think the
report will be a pivotal moment i mean
it does feel as though for ministers and
the prime minister right now the
report's almost useful and because they
can just uh you know stonewall any
questions by saying just wait just wait
a few weeks i think the report will be
quite factual and i don't i think one of
the reasons why um some of those around
restaurants are so keen to kind of
emphasize the importance of the report
is
it's not the report's job to write a
sentence like the prime minister should
resign and i think that they will uh
hope to point to the fact the report
doesn't say that and say oh well he's
been cleared time to move on
um
i think the difference between
this
uh report and civil servants are
understandably reluctant to look like
they are forcing a prime minister out if
you think of robin butler's reporting to
the intelligence around iraq's uh
weapons of mass destruction and how that
was used to make the case for war in
2004 or you know even lord gait's letter
to boris johnson about whether he broke
the ministerial code over the
arrangements for
redecorating his flat you know they
they don't want to be the person who
looks like they have forced out the
prime minister because you know they
they are an unelected official uh not an
elected politician but i think the
difference between this story and those
stories is this is
a very simple story for the public to
understand this isn't about whether
intelligence should be triple sourced as
opposed to single source the difference
between human intelligence and signals
intelligence
it's something much more simple and
something that people feel far more
viscerally and i think this is one of
the things that the tory mps are saying
is you know
that those rules in the first lockdown
were so strict that they're that people
are kind of really furious at the idea
that uh the people in government who
were making those rules were were
finding ways um to stay within the rules
but do things that other people weren't
doing and i think that that is that is
where it is so dangerous for boris
johnson
rod one of the things that appears to be
keeping boris johnson safe or safer um
is ultimately the fact there is no
consensus right now and who should
replace him and therefore you wouldn't
really have a neat uh successor brought
in you could have actually quite a messy
contest is there anyone who has caught
your eye as someone who would do a
better job
yes julian closten the leader of the
social democratic party but him aside
and he's probably not in the running
katie at this point um
[Music]
yeah i mean obviously uh i spoke to a
conservative mp this morning who told me
that there were 250 of his colleagues
who wanted boris out i mean he said 250.
uh and i
i think the the some of the press and
some of the commentators have got it
into their heads that
there will be a kind of genial
coronation of rishi sunak
but there's quite a lot of people within
the conservative party who do not want
rishi sunak uh largely because of his
fiscal policies um and there are even
more people in that party who don't want
lose trust uh for various reasons um so
i think you probably i know james will
probably write and i'm sure knows his
fault better than i do but my guess is
that when a leadership election does
come along and my guess is that it will
come along sometime within the next four
to six months you know
uh that when it does come along there'll
be six or seven people on there and the
great lesson of conservative party
leadership campaigns is that the
favorite never wins
james do you think that they'll be able
to fit all the candidates in a potential
tory leadership contest in one room
i think there'll be no shortage of
candidates i think again as happened
last time there will have to be some
kind of winnowing process you know the
rules don't
don't formally require people to have a
certain amount of support but i think
that that is what is going to have to
happen because you know when you are in
government you cannot have a contest
with 15 candidates at the start of it uh
i i think that will undoubtedly be a
contest i think that you know i think
there's a there's an odd jockeying um no
one wants to be the front runner and
into a leadership contest for the for
the reasons that rod says and i think so
much of these tour leadership contests
depends on the pres on the timing the
precise way in which this thing starts
um i think the but i think one of the
things i will say is that when parties
pick successors they always tend to go
for someone who is uh the opposite of
what went before so uh the tory party
went from uh you know if you go through
it from margaret thatcher's
domineeringness to kind of john major
with his desire to just kind of you know
whip's desire to kind of keep the party
together they went from uh the
smoothness of david cameron to uh
theresa may's very different persona
they went from theresa may to boris
johnson so i think the person who
succeeds boris johnson if there is a
leadership contest will be someone who
who feels very different to him in terms
of political style and approach
well indeed a good point james so in
other words they're probably going to
choose someone
competent and honest
rod can you think of anyone who had
fallen into that category
uh but can i think of any well you see i
i i always go with the crowd as a social
conservative therefore uh i quite like
uh
uh liz truss at the moment uh but
whether she i mean people become
people think that
that uh john major for example uh was
not a a born leader a born prime
minister but uh and in fact in my
opinion he turned out not to be a
terribly good prime minister or leader
but uh we we don't think of people
inhabiting that role until they actually
inhabit it um and so frankly it could be
pretty much anyone i don't know the
runners and riders i just hope it's
someone
who is a social conservative and who can
roll back a bit against uh
in the cultural war which i think is one
of the reasons uh an important reason
why those red wool seats went to the
conservatives last time around it was
far less the attraction of boris and far
more uh uh a thorough going dislike of
the anti-patriotic anti-patriotism and
wokeness of corbyn
now james we're talking about what a
potential tory leadership contest this
year would look like but perhaps you
could help us envisage the other
scenario um which is still possible
boris johnson has bounced back before
what do you think the scenario is where
boris johnson actually does get through
this and what does he then need to do to
secure his position if he can do
anything
i think the scenario when she gets
through this is
the grey report is quite factual it
doesn't contain direct criticism of him
uh
he saw you know that there are
various senior heads in downing street
role on both the political and the civil
service side allowing him to say that
he's cleaned house
tory mps decide to stay their hand you
know say look let's wait until we see
what the results these may local
elections are and then kind of gradually
kind of other political issues come to
the fore cost of living energy crisis
um
then you have the may elections they're
bad but they're not catastrophic you
know he says look this is kind of
classic midterm problems for the
government and we're coming out with
measures soon to help people with the
cost of living and you know it goes on
and
and it's worth remembering that you know
that
always one of the reasons why uh party
leaders and particularly prime ministers
survive
is that that their mps want to wait for
the kind of perfect moment to change
leader or the perfect moment to to to
trigger a contest
and there is never such a thing in
politics and that i think is the way
that boris johnson comes back and then
he starts to say look we got out of uh
covered restrictions before other places
because of the decisions that i took
and
he he can rebuild that way but i think
one of the things that will be difficult
for him is that even before uh this
story broke um
this year didn't look like it was gonna
have much political good news for him in
it
given you know the squeeze on cost of
living from inflation rising energy
bills and all of those things and i also
think he's at that difficult phase of
his premiership where um
there is at the beginning of your
apprenticeship big statements so if he
came out and said we're going to turn
around every boat in the channel that
rally supports you once you have been in
office for as long as he has now when
you say things people are waiting to see
whether they actually happen
rather than just giving you applause for
what you say
and finally rod is there anything boris
johnson could say that would make you
change your mind then make you think
actually he is the right person to lead
the party
no i don't think so but i think i think
james is right and i think that that's
not an unlikely scenario that he does
continue to battle onward i mean i think
the main the may elections
are important if you if you if they if
they
reflect what the polls are saying now
which is that you know uh 36 of people
who voted conservative in red hall seats
will now no longer do so then that puts
a whole raft of seats up for grabs
especially where i am at the moment in
two side uh virtually the whole of two
side uh or when conservative apart from
middlesbrough central
um
once that happens then
you do have a whole bunch of very very
nervous mps who will be agitating for
change as well as those in the party
excuse me who would never terribly happy
with boris in the first case
and actually
if you think about it
june july for a leadership contest it's
actually not a bad time for the
conservatives to do that
exactly mid-term but
you know you get a new leader in
honeymoon period things look good for a
bit
you hold another election and probably
win it you know that's
that's the other scenario but i think
james's notion that that he may well get
away with it and just bluster on through
is quite possible
thank you rod thank you james
so the prime minister urged mps to wait
until sue grey the civil servant looking
into number 10 parties finishes her
inquiry so who is gray and what might
she say about the prime minister
i'm joined now by jill rutter a former
civil servant who is now a senior fellow
at the institute of government
jill this week is not just boris johnson
who we keep hearing about it's also
someone called sue gray
when a politician doesn't want to answer
a question about various parties and the
frequent replies let's wait till sue
gray has finished investigating now sue
grey is a civil servant can you tell us
a bit about her
so sue gray is quite an interesting
person she's
a very senior civil servant she's
her day job is as a second permanent
secretary
uh shared between the cabinet office and
michael gove's leveling up department
because she's in charge of relations
with the devolved government she
actually at the sort of times of the
lockdown it's quite interesting that
she's only just recently come back to
the cabinet office from northern ireland
where she went off to be permanent
secretary at the department of finance
um put her pat in the ring to be head of
the northern ireland civil service which
is separate civil service
but didn't get that job and so came back
to london
but where she really you know came to a
degree of public attention obviously
nothing like now is as director general
of propriety and ethics
in the cabinet office where for the
cabinet secretary and successes prime
ministers she would investigate
uh dubious behavior by a variety of
ministers so for example
it was sue gray that put the kibosh on
damien green's career over yeah his uh
the investigation into him
uh so that's sue gray's track record so
she's been there done that in terms of
investigations before what she's never
really had to do before is do something
where the buck might very well end up
with the prime minister so that's a the
distinct awkwardness of this particular
investigation and of course she's only
doing it now because it was originally
tasked to the cabinet secretary simon
case but then ten days later he had to
recuse himself when it was revealed that
he might have been at a party in the
cabinet office
and as you say jill it's a very unusual
situation to have a civil servant
ultimately in charge of a report that
could uh really severely impact the
prime minister's position and therefore
there does seem to be some confusion
over how um bad this report could really
be for boris johnson and because
ministers have ultimately all said oh
we'll wait to this report boris johnson
has also said wait to this report before
you get there i think some think it
could say something along the lines of
you know boris johnson broke the law he
must go but that's not quite what we're
talking about is it what is it more
realistically going to say in terms of
the various scenarios
so the
thing she was asked to investigate was
whether there were parties because
remember this investigation was set up
when that
video that the prime minister told the
commons he was shocked by the uh legra
stratton
video came out and the prime minister
had still been telling parliament that
there were no parties that guidance was
followed at all times
so uh sue gray's really trying to
establish the facts about were there
parties um
the interesting thing is how much
further does she go than that does she
tell us
she'd probably say some things about the
culture in number 10 and the way they
treated that
does she go into
why did they think they were compatible
with the
prevailing guidance and rules at the
time we know the guidance rules are a
bit different sometimes so why do they
think this was okay
does she tell us anything about who were
the movers and shakers behind having
these parties
uh does she tell us anything about what
the prime minister
knew or didn't know i don't know how
narrowly or widely she'll interpret her
remit
i think she's in a really really
difficult position what sue gray won't
do though
is say
the prime minister must go
that really she will pass the ball over
to two p two different sort of sets of
people
one for the sort of fallout for any
civil servants implicated and criticized
in her report if she does that
then any disciplinary action doesn't
fall to sue gray it falls to simon case
as the head of the civil service
any fallout for the prime minister
uh
she can't do that she's not going to say
boris johnson's got to go
um basically hand the report to the
prime minister the prime minister could
decide to refer himself
to lord geit or to the parliamentary
standards commissioner possibly uh who
can make judgments on whether he
breached the minister or code
um but really really really the
important action then
turns to the prime minister's back bench
colleagues uh and his ministers in his
cabinet do they think
that based on whatever facts sue grey
chooses to expose and what evidence she
uncovers that the prime minister
uh can't go on and that's really for
them to determine so
yeah the problem for sue gray
is that she's really on a bit of a
hiding to nothing i think the civil
service should never
accepted that it would investigate this
because at the moment she's a convenient
delaying tactic but the trouble is that
her report risks satisfying absolutely
nobody
uh there will be people who say
the civil service is trying to get at
the prime minister we've had quite a
tricky
period for relations between ministers
and civil service
and if you know it increases the
pressure on the prime minister people
will say well we always knew the civil
service didn't like this government very
much uh if however it you know gives
meat to those who want to exonerate the
prime minister then she'll be accused of
doing a whitewash for her political
masters so i think it's a really really
difficult position just shows why
actually she never asked a civil servant
to investigate the prime minister
and and as you touch on i mean we've
already seen jacob rees-mogg the leader
of the house and talk about how if there
you know hr and a report ultimately
civil servants who should lose their
jobs um rather than politicians that
would not be the the right way about
going about things and before i suppose
we get onto potentially civil servants
who could be vulnerable i just wondered
one of the things that sue grey's report
could do is bring more evidence to light
put it in the public realm and
what access does she get will she be
able to look at things like cctv um we
know when it comes to for example that
email which was leaked um from martin
reynolds inviting staff to a drinks
party that would be something she has
holder but what kind of teeth does she
have when it comes to getting
information
so the interesting thing is that the
team is basically her old team uh
including the guy a guy called darren
tierney who's doing her old job as
director general of propriety and ethics
so what just changed was who was at the
top of the investigation um but these
aren't like super sleuths i mean yes
they will be asking people
uh
interviewing people uh asking them what
went on uh interviewing a lot of people
in number 10 i imagine
they may have asked for access that
anyone has to memos whether people
disclose them or whether we find that
the people
outside government actually have better
access to sue gray i mean it would be
really interesting to know whether she
knew about the 20th of may
party
in its full glory before it you know
dominic cummings sort of put it into the
public domain and that memo was
leaked to paul brand at itv we don't
know that um
i think when the real risk for sugray is
that people think that she's been a bit
over hasty and not got the full
information out but you know this isn't
a sort of police investigation uh it's a
disciplinary
if you like investigation to see whether
uh about behavior internally so it's
more an hr style investigation
so she'll depend on you know people
wanting to cooperate with their bosses
but the clear message
from simon casey's civil servant should
be that you have to engage with sue gray
and let her have all the information
that you have downing street as you say
does have sort of security videos we saw
that in the famous pleb gate
investigation into andrew mitchell that
those security cameras there but
is it that obvious i mean the people
working in number 10
she might be able to say when for
example at the famous 18th december
party the first party were there lots of
outsiders that booked into number 10
when you go to number 10 as you know
katie you have to sort of sign in you
know show your past be on a list
uh she might want to look at that but if
it's just staff in number 10
uh do we know that you know
are there photographs of people going in
you know handing big crates of booze or
whatever or did they just have a sort of
few cans in their backpack a bit
difficult to tell and i know when i went
to number 10 i was always a bit
embarrassed about being caught on camera
going into number 10 with that week's
stash of diet cokes to get me through
the week so
yeah i mean
people do
work there as well as a party there so
it's quite difficult in that sense to do
that so
um does she interview dorman i don't
know i mean you know it's up for her to
decide how to do it and to balance i
think almost the need for speed
uh against the need for this to be
clearly a sort of you know thorough job
and sue gray
will also have an eye on her own
personal reputation i mean she'll want
to have been seen to have done a good
thorough professional and fair job
because ultimately a lot of job people's
you know future careers could be
blighted by what she says
so she has to be quite careful that she
is genuinely fair to those
yeah and just and just finally um we
talked about how ultimately ousting a
prime minister is always going to be a
political decision but there are some uh
other figures martin reynolds um the
senior um
adviser to boris johnson civil service
who um ultimately sent that email um and
so do you think we could start to see
civil servants referred for um
disciplinary or that could be the
perhaps the scalps of this report
well that will ultimately be a decision
for simon case assuming of course that
simon case himself doesn't come in for
criticism in the report which is also
possible
uh i think you know
it'll be very interesting to see how
this plays if there's absolutely sort of
unequivocal evidence that civil servants
in number 10
uh basically
indulge in sort of serial rule breaking
then i think it'd be very difficult for
them to stay there and indeed those are
the very people who should have been
advising the prime minister if the prime
minister had come down and said oh it's
a nice day you know
we should thank staff at a work event
outside and the several servants hadn't
sort of advised well prime minister we
think that you know would look very
incompatible with the guidance that
oliver down was just about to tell the
nation about at the downing street press
conference i mean you know you would
possibly just criticize civil servants
even if their involvement was only that
if they were the movers and shakers
behind this and that's a that's a
different thing and i think on the test
for the civil service
is how does it handle that if something
looks the public like sort of really
egregious behavior but the civil
services response is to try and brush it
under a carpet and just perhaps slightly
sooner than might otherwise have
happened move that person into the job
they would have got anyway
then i think the civil service will
probably be criticized for not taking
this
seriously enough so i think there's uh
there's going to be quite a tricky
question the other big question i think
for number 10 and i don't know whether
sue gray will see that says within her
remit at all or not
is on what basis did the prime minister
give all those assurances
that the guidelines were followed at all
times because that really is one of the
big issues for the prime minister
notwithstanding whether he went to that
particular party or not there's also a
big issue
about whether he
you know
misled parliament you can say
certainly looked a bit economical with
what he admitted to knowing about
given what has happened in number 10 and
i don't know whether sue grey is going
to go into how number 10 handled
the questioning about this because
clearly they weren't at all forthcoming
until that initial video leak forced
their hand
thank you
[Music]
you